interesting thing going on with
deportations of undocumented immigrants
you'll remember that our current
president promised to be the big de
Porter he'd get the country cleaned up
of the not the best people that Mexico
has been sending us law and order all of
that type of thing and it is true that
the Trump administration has been
bragging about and has been making more
arrests right immigration officials from
ice have been making more arrests for
people who are on who have immigration
status violations since he became
president of the United States but more
arrests does not mean more deportations
especially when the arrests are pretty
haphazard deportations are actually down
under Trump now I'm not complaining I'm
not passing a value judgment on this I'm
just pointing out to you that the
rhetoric has been everybody's gonna go
out and then they can come back in maybe
legally through a beautiful door in the
as yell as yet-to-be-built wall that
Mexico will pay for but deportations are
down the numbers show that the Trump
administration is on pace for fewer
deportations in 2017 than in 2016 under
President Barack Obama and there are 43
percent more arrests so how do the
numbers add up more arrests way more
arrests but way fewer deportations the
pledge from Trump was to arrest and
deport so-called criminal illegal aliens
three million drug dealers that Trump
says are around and gang members and
other criminals who have committed
crimes in addition to being undocumented
in the United States
Isis having trouble finding them right
43 percent more arrests by ice but it's
mostly people with no criminal record
who are just in the u.s. undocumented in
addition Trump's rhetoric around
immigration has made it so that a ton of
nonprofits have raised way more money in
donations they are now providing pro
bono legal help to undocumented
immigrants and that is slowing down
deportation so consider the big picture
of what's happening here Trump wants to
keep us safe so he says we're going to
start arresting way more people and
deporting them ice rather than targeting
specific undocumented
who have committed violent and other
crimes and would qualify for quick
deportation ice starts haphazardly
arresting everybody with an immigration
status violation it fills up the system
with people that are low priority with
deportation many of them end up getting
free legal representation as a result of
Trump's rhetoric and then the entire law
enforcement and immigration and legal
apparatus gets gummed up because it's
full of people who have been arrested on
immigration status violation violations
but actually haven't committed any
crimes it's backwards it's a total
gongshow and if your question is well
how will the Trump administration talk
about this they'll just say Isis doing a
fantastic job tremendous really did you
know arrests are up a lot of people
didn't know that but they are we're
arresting more illegals than ever before
stunning really amazing what Barron can
do with computers they're going out and
maybe someday they'll come back in but
they're just being arrested by ice and
deportations are down if you are a
committed trumpet how do you defend this
how do you justify this and again I'm
not saying this is a good thing I'm not
saying I support the policy but if
you're a trumpet and you believed what
Trump was going to do how do you defend
this or do you just pretend it's not
going on the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership